James Darcy plays Edwin Jarvis as he did
an agent Carter behind them on a bench
is an extra who I think looks a lot like
Loki and in my head Canon will always be
nebula and Roadie intercept Peter Quill
on Morag
but they don't use Quill's gravity snare
to take the Power Stone like he did in
Guardians 1. it said nebula Burns her
robot hand they do this to give us a
visual clue later on if it'd be an evil
nebula with an undamaged hand who opens
up the quantum tunnel to let Thanos
through in the script revealed that in
2014 Gamora nebulous combatants were
corbinites the race of Beta Ray Bill
down on the planet Corbin explosions
black out half of the city they're
really sticking to that 50 aren't they
Thanos later uncovers the Time Heist and
sees his destiny
unreal
the word unruly he's calling back the
others description of the Avengers
[Music]